1896 léon gaumont vient de mettre au
point le chrono photographe l'une des
toutes premières caméras le cinéma
n'existe pas encore mais nous sommes à
l'aube d'une révolution qui commence
aujourd'hui
m
[Musique]
les nordistes c'est un client qui
arrivent ici minutes allo c'est moi le
client désolé léon c'est le seul moyen
que j'ai trouvé pour avoir un peu de
votre temps
j'ai une idée pour vendre mieux nos
appareils de prise de vue une secrétaire
avec des idées n'arrête pas le progrès
génial d'entendre ça
qu'est ce que je suis en train de
regarder l'histoire mais toi
vous connaissez la légende qui raconte
que les garçons naissent dans les choux
pommés ou là dans un jardin d'enfants
les gens aiment les histoires lire je
pense que nous devrions utiliser nos
appareils pour fabriquer des histoires
avec que les gens prendraient plaisir à
regarder comme il aime se plonger dans
un bon livre
si on les fait rêver avec notre appareil
c'est sûr ils voudront lâcheté des
histoires sur film mais oui on prendrait
des comédiens de théâtre et ont capturé
leur prestation avec d'autres appareils
oui et pour la fée au sujet pensé à tout
je vais fabriquer les costumes et décors
les accessoires et puis ensuite on
construire une salle avec des sièges et
les spectateurs viendrait après le
souper voir les petites histoires
primesautière concoctée par benoît celle
est qui on pourrait même lui faire payer
le prix voilà j'ai tout entendu
aujourd'hui par dont j'ai toujours une
imagination débordante
cela dit elles ne trouvent écho que chez
ceux qui ont des ambitions
il y aurait peut-être des meilleurs si
vous faisiez votre travail liste story
dont felix von trier plus et moi essayer
nos clients achètent nos appareils pour
documenter les scènes du quotidien la
nature le travail un trac hier entre en
gare condat a pour vocation de vendre
des histoires mais vendre du matériel
professionnel vous ne vous rendez pas
compte du potentiel de notre appareil
c'est mon appareil et je compte revendre
comme je l'entends et ont je pense que
gaumont le pouvoir de faire rêver les
gens
ses clients même le monde entier comme
du temps berga devant vous comme jules
verne ou comme mozart leon 2 qui se
souvient aujourd'hui de mozart ou de
celui qui lui a vendu son canot je
ferais cela en dehors de mes horaires de
travail vous ne remarquerez même par ses
propos n'insistez pas
voici tu veux mon avis c'est chaud les
faits pareils mais ce n'est pas une
lubie
ernestine je te comprends aller sans
nous les femmes on a besoin de se
réaliser
oui et moi ma marotte et ben c'est le
crochet mais si tu veux je te passer une
pelote une paire d'aiguilhe attend à ce
que j'avais toujours une en plus c'est
quand même important de sortir quelque
chose de ses dix doigts
artistiquement il se passe quelque chose
c'est et puis ça fait plaisir à la
condition que votre courrier n'en
souffre pas léon gaumont
[Musique]
ça
m
[Applaudissements]
nous avons
[Musique]